yeah
good morning
monkey yeah what are we doing right now
what did you do make pancakes and y'alls
are bigger than mine but you have fruits
and i have a joke
yep literally you have junk and i have
fruit so mine
blueberry mine has some blueberries
okay here bite it so that we can see
what it looks like on the inside
is it melted
oh oh sorry dude okay
besides eating junk food in the morning
what else are we doing
we put some
sugar on mine me i put some you
and then you put and then we put
chocolate chips and you put blueberries
and then we go to the dentist after that
yeah we're gonna go to dentists after
this good job
so taika is at the dentist right now are
you nervous dude nope not at all
about the different ones yeah what do
you think they're going to find in your
mouth um though i see that my kids are
stronger did you see your teeth are
strong like yeah oh okay
you can take them out
well i don't know if you want that but i
don't think they're going to take them
up look at the computer screen you can
see all these teeth in there
those those are dino those are animal
teeth no those are human teeth
yeah but with the pointy teeth well
that's the root that's that's inside
your gum you don't see that part
it's like a big blanket is that okay
yeah it's okay
yeah yeah okay i'm gonna show you my
camera
cool
oh it's like an elevator
[Music]
okay so when i put this in you're gonna
do that okay okay you remember
okay yeah open big i'm going to put this
down okay sweetie is that okay are you
invited yeah we're going to bite you
open your mouth open
you're going to take a picture
big big big big open big and then
i know we're just all right
hold on let's try one more thing open
big
ah
and then pretend open big eyes
no take one over here okay we're gonna
take another picture
yeah it's gonna feel kind of funny but
it's okay
[Music]
look i got it
look at that one
you see you big baby let's do one over
here okay
all right take us being super brave now
it's okay hold it hold it let's see what
happened
oh we could have missed that one did we
do that okay
we missed it a little bit okay taika how
was your first x-ray experience
was it scary you nervous did you ever
think you were gonna like i don't know
cry
was it good yeah i was looking in there
what's in there
what's that electricity it's just a
bunch of
um
i don't know like boxes for all the
programs and stuff that they run okay
you're gonna do another x-ray of all
your mouths yeah
well i'm happy you're not scared dude
[Music]
oh you're a little too short okay we're
gonna do this
all right
tech
so you're gonna hold on to there don't
touch anything here
do you know what a chin is monkey good
job yeah
okay i'm gonna drop this down because i
need your chin there oh perfect that's
perfect you're gonna bite down
hold on to the bar please
oh
it's gonna take pictures of my youtube
channel
oh you can watch it from the
you're almost mirror
right there
good job i kind of messed up oh my god
look at all those teeth that are waiting
to come out dude
all right so far tuck has been doing
amazing not scared not crying having the
time of his life the complete opposite
of my death experiences so
i'm in heaven right now because the last
thing i want is a crime baby
this guy loves looking at himself
and then i'm going to take one from the
side so don't move
cutie pie good job
[Music]
is having way too much fun over here
good job one more open big eye
and i'm gonna go back here and see those
teeth
are you scared of the um
of air
no he's not scared of anything do you
want to touch it out
that's the air
and that's why wow yeah okay is that
cool so then that's what she's gonna do
she's gonna put air in like this
what's in your mouth
[Music]
wow
i just want to remove the saliva
open open up she doesn't want you to wet
your mouth
there you go
you're cool
no talking
don't move your tongue around no she
needs to take pictures get your tongue
do you love the camera better than the
x-rays huh
he loves seeing himself
how can you put water in my mouth
no dude let her do her job
please move your tongue and then we're
going to get a third toy right you want
a third toy
oh
don't no no move your tongue
okay
this is air water syringe i'm gonna turn
this on look then i'm going to go like
this
close your mouth there you go yes
that's all i'm going to do
i like that
now we're playing a matching game and
taika is already winning oh great okay
now it's my turn let me see
there's that one a jelly and let's see
again nope
okay it's grandpa's turn i got two and
two okay grandpa has the candy cane
let's see if he remembers
nope i like this turn
i saw that oh
monkey who won count it one two three
four five six seven eight nine
how about how many did mama get uh
two three four five
one
two
three
four
[Laughter]
now it's dinner time and taika
gets his
pizza
hi
[Music]
oh anyway he's back up he tricked
everybody he didn't sink he's right
there
did you just open the portal
tech has been doing this dance for like
literally five minutes and it gets real
whoa wait no
don't get creative no get down
and i'm watching the fights
the ufc fight
okay but he's still going so i had to
just show you guys because this is just
nuts
oh and he's doing magic at the same time
oh and beatboxing oh and he disappeared
oh wait he's back the magic the magician
the dancing
beatboxer breakdancer magician
tychaquan
whoa
look at all the handstand tricks
whoa are you okay
oh nothing can stop him
oh my god
you okay oh maybe that could stop him
you okay
you want some water
yeah
okay
no no drink some water it's in the
fridge it's cold
he can be stopped ladies and gentlemen
he can be stopped oh no he can't he's
still going
oh my god be careful
oh no he's got a little puppet monkey
oh whoa he's still going folks